l'ingénieur ce bonjour l'ukraine et les
pays occidentaux parlent de crime de
vagues guerre voire de génocide la
russie elle dément elle parle d'image
fabriqués par kiev pour les médias
occidentaux quels sont les faits
virginie de quelles preuves dispose-t-on
alors pour l'instant des preuves il n'y
en a pas énormément il ya beaucoup de
témoignages mais ce qu'on sait c'est que
effectivement il y a par exemple la
butch à une vingtaine de corps qui
étaient dans la rue d'après les
journalistes qui ont pu se rendre sur
place les visages étaient plutôt cireux
donc ce qui laisse à penser que des
corps et elle a déjà depuis plusieurs
jours mais que ce soit du new york times
la france 2 ou encore d'autres
journalistes parle effectivement de
corps de civils qu'on trouve dans les
zones qui sont maintenant reprise par
les ukrainiens et où étaient tous
étaient les russes et dont il va falloir
évidemment mener des enquêtes ces
enquêtes repose sur des témoignages sur
des photos également voir la position
des corps et il ya une petite confusion
ces derniers temps en raison aussi du
nombre de personnes qui ont été trouvés
ce qui me racontent certains habitants
c'est que ils ont trouvé eux aussi des
corps dans l'ariège dans des arrière
cours dans des jardins et ont dû dans la
précipitation enterrer rapidement pour
des questions sanitaires notamment des
des personnes des civils qui ont été qui
ont été tués donc l'an qu'elle va se
faire et les enquêtes dont se faire au
fur et à mesure et c'est certain que à
mesure que justement les ukrainiens vont
reprendre position dans certaines villes
on entra entre a de plus en plus ce
genre ce genre de témoignage et donc des
organisations comme human rights watch
par exemple a commencé à enquêter human
rights watch qui a sorti un premier
bilan hier où il parlait effectivement
de possibles crimes de guerre et
d'exactions commises par des russes
notamment à bout de chats et déjà sa
date du 3 mars dernier les occidentaux
veulent de nouvelles sanctions emmanuel
macron notamment s'est dit ce matin
favorable à ce que l'union européenne
prenne un nouveau train de sanctions au
delà de ça il y aura vous le disiez
certainement des enquêtes l'onu par le
don enquête indépendante également ou
alors il y aura probablement des
sanctions économiques qui vont être
renforcés joseph bourrel haut
représentant de l'union européenne pour
les affaires étrangères
un de le déclarer a dit que l'ue allait
se réunir en urgence pour discuter de
ces les sanctions c'est que le
chancelier allemand également appel à de
nouvelles sanctions et en parallèle donc
des enquêtes menées par la justice
justice internationale et des justices
nationales internationales on va
peut-être le voir à l'écran il ya
différentes possibilités yakup pénale de
la cour pénale internationale qui est à
l'ail qui va poursuivre des individus
une première enquête a été lancée le 2
mars dernier des enquêtes aussi qui
concerne par exemple l'usagé de bombes à
sous-munitions encore le bombardement de
l'hôpital de marioupol le problème c'est
que la russie est sortie du traité qui a
formé la cpi en 2016 et donc du coup
même si des individus sont condamnés ils
vont ne vont pas être extradé par par
moscou l'autre possibilité c'est la cour
internationale de justice qui est un
organe dépendant de l'onu et qui lui
s'occupe des de la responsabilité des
états une enquête là encore a été lancé
le 4 mars dernier suite à un vote du
conseil des droits humains à l'onu est
une quarantaine d'enquêteurs commence
déjà à plancher nous on travaillait à
peu près pendant un an au delà de ça il
y a également les des appels à créer un
tribunal adot très bien la drogue c'est
à dire un tribunal international qui
serait compétent spécifiquement sur
cette question pour aller vite parce
qu'on le sait on l'a vu dans les dents
des conflits précédents la justice
internationale peut être parfois très
très très très lente et en dehors de ces
trois possibilités donc de justice
internationale il ya également en
allemagne et en espagne
les procureurs qui se sont dits en
enfin en raison du principe de
compétence universelle
par nom qui ont dit il lancé des
instructions merci beaucoup pour cet
éclair